Sam asgari appears unfazed by headlines
about wife Britney Spears who slamming
rumors she dodged an intervention I just
want to be a happy person
the actor steps out for the season three
premiere of Star Trek Picard all smiles
but didn't stop to chat on the red
carpet on Sam's Instagram story he jokes
that fans think he is Rob Kardashian and
earlier this message enjoy the day
meanwhile no joy over on his wife's
social media I'm at least confident
about a lot of things where the princess
of pop denies reports of substance abuse
and an intervention planned by her Inner
Circle try to keep it kind of
professional we're hearing Britney has
quote struggled with drugs over the
years family and friends have gotten so
concerned over her health and plan to
give her help TMZ first reported the
story claiming the intervention fell
apart when Brittany got wind of the plan
their Source close to Brittany said
quote I'm afraid she's gonna die I'm a
very strong woman Brittany writes it
makes me sick to my stomach that it's
even legal for people to make up stories
that I almost died at some point enough
is enough adding quote my hubby's says
it best don't believe everything you
read fans know Sam has showed public
support for his love time and time again
[Music]
from the early days of their romance and
you guys know my situation to the end
Britney's conservatorship she's doing
great I'm great I'm just it's the
happiest time of our lives and we're
just enjoying it of course their Journey
led to the couple's fairy tale I Do's
last year look at that
you like it I love the most about my
relationship is the fact that it's it's
so normal and Brittany in Sam's next
chapter a seemingly Happy video to the
two twinning at Target on Wednesday it
was shared on Sam's account where fans
might need to go for their Britney
content moving forward as she put it in
her Instagram message on Thursday I'm
probably going to have to stop posting
on Instagram because though I enjoy
doing it there's obviously a lot of
people who don't wish me well well you
know we're all human so
foreign